all right the tampa bay buccaneer so i'm
told of the defending nfl champion super
bowl 55 and they are still basking in
the glow of that it seems like every
time i go to twitter there's another
interview that bruce arians has done
with someone i mean hey he went plenty
of years with no one want to talk to him
now everybody wants to talk to him he
may as well say yes to everybody who
asks jason
absolutely and now he's got a tattoo on
his back to go along with it jason light
who you may remember from the start of
the show talking about whether or not he
will get a tattoo he said he won't for
this year maybe for next year maybe on
his face which would be awesome but he
was kidding he was asked during that
same press conference about the reality
that the buccaneers with all of these
avoidable year contracts are loading up
the cannon pun intended now although i
really didn't see it coming
understanding that they are in a salary
cap mess in the future here's light
there seems to kind of i guess be a
misconception that you guys are going to
be in some type of salary cap hell
because you are using uh some some
different strategies to construct these
contracts like voidable years can you
just kind of clear that up a little bit
and you know how much work is going to
need to be done in the future with your
cap situation
well there there's some corrections that
you're gonna that are gonna have to take
place at some point down the road but
it's not good we're not in a position
we're not putting ourselves in a
position where
next year we have to release a lot of
good players um we're going to be in
good shape if we continue to just make
sure that we
that we make smart decisions and we do
things right um we're going to be
you know competing for for years to come
i look you can say that but the truth is
they're going all in they went all in
last year and they won the super bowl
they're going all in again this year and
they won the super bowl there will be a
reckoning when tom brady leaves they're
going to have a problem i know bruce
erin said earlier this week they don't
rule out drafting a quarterback at
number 32.
and and one of the things that light
also said miles they do have the luxury
this year in the draft because they're
bringing back all 22 starters they don't
need to go out and get somebody to plug
in that's going to be a difference maker
they can work on development for the
future but this team is going all in for
the second straight year it worked last
year they're going all in again eat
drink and be merry for tomorrow we will
be
seven and ten that's their attitude and
i'm still i'm still
working on
factoring in that extra game into
predictions of team records it sounded
extremely foreign when you said it i was
like what the hell is he talking about
and i was like oh no it's 17 games in
the regular season now so yeah i think
the whole premise of this thing with uh
the buccaneers and saying oh boy they're
going to be in salary cap hell in a
couple years who cares who cares if
they're in salary capital in a couple of
years they have tom brady now they won
the super bowl last season they're gonna
try to win it again this season we
already know what these starters can do
they're all back that's exactly what you
should do when you have a tom brady
who's gonna be 44 years old and is still
playing like a top five quarterback in
this league you go all in you push all
of your chips into the middle of the
table and you say yeah we're going for
it damn the future it doesn't matter we
are we are playing for today we are
living for today and that is exactly
what they should be doing and i love
that they're doing it because honestly
you know if i'm bruce arians
am i really going to be around when tom
brady's not there no jason light
probably will be
but who knows so just push all your
chips in go for it i love it
well and from 2003 until
2020
they were mediocre
they couldn't get out of their own way
they couldn't put fans in the stands
they're going to ride this and they're
going to enjoy this and they'll worry
about tomorrow when tomorrow comes look
in today's nfl
this idea of a five-year plan or a
three-year plan even that doesn't work
what it's about is each and every year
being it's in
in its own independent entity
and you make the moves you have to make
to be as good as you can be and when you
happen to have a great nucleus of
players
you you milk that for all it's worth and
then at some point they do have to set
about the the task of finding a
long-term answer at the quarterback
position
that is coming for now that's something
they don't have to worry about and i
mean really they went from jameis
winston who was the first overall pick
in the draft straight into tom brady and
they'll carry tom brady
or he will carry them until he's done
and then they'll worry about it when
he's when he's gone and that's fine they
may have two super bowl championships
maybe three by the time the tom brady
finally walks away so enjoy it while it
lasts because for too many teams it
never even shows up antonio brown you
saw the graphic earlier he's the last of
the eight key free agents
who has they've all resigned but for him
reportedly antonio brown of the
buccaneers aren't close to a deal
earlier this week bruce aryan said that
there are offers out it tells me that
maybe there's a one year a two-year
multi-year different things on the menu
that antonio brown can choose from but
the price not right for antonio brown
and look here's a guy who has come back
he's behaved well relative to the reign
of terror that he was involved in most
of 2019 into early 2020 he's won a super
bowl
he's still buried on the depth chart
behind mike evans and chris god when
they're paying god when franchise tag
money i think antonio brown
legitimately and reasonably wants to get
paid and maybe wants to be somewhere
where he will play and he's probably
waiting at this point for someone to
come along and offer something more than
what the buccaneers have put on the
table
i think that that's fair for him to do
that but i also think that he's got a
he's got to kind of decide do i want to
play with somebody who i know really
really likes me and i know really is
going to bring out the best in me and
that's tom brady or am i going to go
someplace else and you know get paid but
also risk that there's going to be
another raiders situation where i feel
like i have to force my way out by being
as much of a problem as i can possibly
be uh through social media through
practice and kicking balls and calling
the general manager names
i don't know
what kind of balance he wants to strike
there i think figuring that out is going
to be the biggest thing for antonio
brown it's really what do you want now i
know we've heard that russell wilson has
been pushing for him to land in seattle
i think that would be an interesting fit
if nothing else um but yeah i just i
don't know i
i think for everybody's sake and maybe
not everybody i don't know i just feel
like he was so such a good fit for what
they were doing in tampa bay especially
because tom brady will always vouch for
that guy apparently
i don't know if there's a better option
for him
professionally
and not necessarily making money but
just in a professional situation in a
professional setting than remaining in
tampa bay
well the problem is he needs to be
somewhere where there will be someone
who can speak to his better angels the
way that tom brady did and the way that
mike tomlin
used to do during all those years where
we didn't know the kind of hell he was
raising behind the scenes and the double
standard that applied to him and him
showing up late to the stadium having
his own off-campus
rental house when everyone else is
sleeping in dorm rooms at st vincent
college in la trobe pennsylvania all the
things they did to keep him happy when
he was full-blown diva in pittsburgh and
nobody said boo about it until the walls
started to crumble around 2018 and
throughout that season i i remember when
the the the problem first started he
landed on the radar screen because
someone was doing an article about
antonio brown and some off-field things
and he said something to the writer or
threatened to hit the writer or
something like that it's like wait a
minute we all thought antonio brown you
know was a was a model citizen and never
in any trouble and then it just kind of
all fell apart they need somebody who
can get him in the mindset he's been in
recently and that he used to be in
pittsburgh and i don't know how many
teams out there fall into that and miles
another thing too i mentioned this
recently either on pft live or pftpm and
we were up against a hard out and i
really didn't get a chance to explain it
the way i wanted to
he has the lingering lawsuit for sexual
assault and rape it's due to go to trial
in december of this year
at some point
he will be placed under oath and ask
questions in a deposition that is a
standard part of the pre-trial process
in civil cases you get asked a bunch of
questions you know i remember when i was
a kid and they would say on tv shows and
in movies a lawyer never asks a question
that the lawyer doesn't already know the
answer to
and it always blew my mind like are they
mind readers too like why would you
worry about practicing law if you can
see the future but the reality is you
know everything there is to know about
the case ahead of time before you go to
trial because you've taken the
deposition testimony and asked every
question that you possibly could from
that witness
and i say that because the lawsuit that
antonio brown was involved in for
throwing a bunch of furniture out of the
window at a luxury
apartment in miami and trashing the
place
he was
as bad as i've ever seen any witness be
at his deposition
belligerent hostile evasive it was so
bad they made him go back again and the
second one was so bad and combined with
all of the other activity that he
engaged in in connection with the case
he lost by forfeit that's how bad he was
and i say all that because
even though
his trial doesn't come until december
and could get continued
at some point between now and september
he's likely to be placed under oath and
if he behaves
in this setting the way he behaved in
the other setting
you're going to have a problem if you're
antonio brown's nfl employer and once
that transcript gets out once that video
gets out once the league catches wind of
it
things could change and his availability
may change and then you always have to
worry about the commissioner exemplist
and you may be paying a guy to not play
for you i think that the people who
understand how the legal system works
and i would say most if not all teams
understand because they got lawyers on
staff to explain this to them they
realize there's risk in having real
money tied up in antonio brown because
depending upon how that deposition goes
he may not be available to anyone this
season miles
yeah and i think that when you put it
like that it almost makes me think well
is that why he's still on the market
because
people will have to understand and
realize that if something like this
would happen right where the deposition
happens and then the deposition comes
out and it turns out that antonio brown
has
reverted back to his former self and you
know not uh applied the better angels
that have been in his ear
um that could really be a problem it
could at least at the very least it
could be a pr problem for a team you
know and you know the most it could be a
field problem an on-field problem
because they're not going to be able to
have antonio brown available to them so
i think that that should be in the minds
of teams right now as they're going
through free agency should be in the
buccaneers mind frankly as they're going
through their process too but i think if
any team probably knows where he's at at
this point in this moment in time it's
the buccaneer so that may or may not
make them more comfortable with the
situation mike yeah and uh look they
really don't need him i hate to say that
but they don't need him they don't they
don't they have mike evans they have
chris godwin they have tyler johnson
they have scottie miller they do not
need antonio brown and they could go
draft a guy in round four or five who
could come in and be just like tyler
johnson was and be ready to go all right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports